foreign
Jerry Hutch walks free from course
acquitted of one of Ireland's most
notorious murders
actually what's your plan now are you
going to stay in Ireland no reaction to
the Court's decision to clear him of the
Regency Hotel murder
that killing was straight from a
Hollywood movie played out for real at a
Dublin Hotel a hit team of Assassins
disguised as a SWAT team carrying AK-47
assault rifles stormed a boxing weigh-in
event at the hotel in February 2016.
their target was Daniel kenahan named an
Irish courts as the leader of the
infamous kinahan cartel
two other assassins one wearing a
woman's wig were already inside hunting
an eyewitness remembers the Panic that
ensued as we were walking out the door
we heard a group of people coming up
behind us rushing out and one person
exclaimed it's all kicking off from
there and we heard of chairs falling
over glass breaking and presumed there's
some kind of melee breaking out three
men dressed and guard a tattoo gear and
carrying assault rifles immersed in the
van and came towards us and they were
shouting at us get the F out of here get
the F down they're pointing their
weapons at us they're scanning the
people we were walking out with uh
checking to see he was coming out
essentially the gunman didn't find
Daniel kinahan but they did Corner one
of his lieutenants 33 year old David
Byrne he was shot six times by two of
the fake police officers dying from
catastrophic injuries in August 2021
Jerry Hutch known as the monk was
arrested by police in Spain and
extradited to Ireland charged with Burns
murder
52 days of evidence were heard at the
non-jury court today the judges said
they doubted the evidence of the key
witness in the case former Sinn Fein
counselor Jonathan dowdahl who turned
State's witness it was fatal to the
prosecution's case Jerry Hutch was free
to go
the murder dramatically escalated the
Hodgkin Feud which went on to claim at
least 18 lives nobody has been convicted
but the relatives of those victims are
serving their own life sentence
the the Regency and what followed had a
devastating impact on the people of the
North Inner City it's not going to be
forgotten too many people are dead too
many families have been affected by it
this is going to go on for Generations
the search for justice continues but the
monk has had his day in court and after
a year and a half in custody is a free
man once more Stephen Murphy Sky News in
Dublin